did you know that the Estus flask from
Dark Souls is actually in Elden ring
back then it was a flask of healing but
now it's used as a smoke bomb by the
Volga militia yeah so this was probably
never meant to be noticed by players but
Elden Rings vulgar militia are actually
throwing little Estus flasks of course
there's no official connection between
the two here but the model used is
undeniably the same model as the classic
flask of previous games as confirmed by
sinuo tante and Great Mighty PO on
Twitter even if the textures involved
are slightly different if you didn't
know the word Estus likely comes from
the Latin astus meaning heat it's quite
fitting for a vessel that literally
stores the heat of bonfires in liquid
form sometimes it feels like an age
since I actually delved into Dark Souls
lore in any depth and if you're someone
who misses those days well I've got a
bit of a surprise for you so I've just
finished narrating over 400 pages of
Dark Souls Lore from a book called
Abyssal archive which is on sale now and
you can listen to it in audiobook form
if you head to the link in the
description Abyssal archive is another
product from The Talented team over at
tune in Fairweather who created Soul
arts for me last year these are gorgeous
books housed in a noble blue slip case
and bound in faux helkite Drake leather
and they just radiate quality the
physical version of Abyssal archive does
command quite a price too admittedly but
that makes sense when you realize that
what you're getting is also years of
lore analysis done by Loki who is one of
the best writers of soulsthor that I've
ever met and there's a third book that
actually comes with your purchase too
I've never seen anything like this
before but it's a thinner book that
folds out into this incredible expansive
world map of lordran Illustrated in the
style of Elden Ring's own map which is
just such a genius idea I love it dark
souls has such an intertwined world and
these Pages show that off like nothing
else so if you're interested in having
Dark Souls lore in book form check the
link in the description and go and
purchase my audiobook or pick up a
physical copy
speaking of picking things up Elden ring
added an item Rarity system to items
found around the world which allows you
to easily distinguish between minor
items regular items arterial leaves and
lastly legendary items but what if there
was a fifth Rarity well recently Twitter
user chain failure discovered this cut
dropped item effect a reddish orange
glow that extends really high into the
space above it meaning it'd be pretty
hard for a player to miss any item with
this glow now items with this effect
obviously don't appear anywhere in game
now but that raises the question if this
effect had been left in game what item
would this glow have been used to
represent personally I think this effect
might be related to the Elden ring and
the greater will for one the runic
symbols above it look a little bit like
those on the cipher weapons which
represent the greater Wills language of
light and if you look closely as chain
failure does in their post you can see
little crystallized shards float around
it as well the same crystallized shards
that appear around sights of Grace
finally as consumable runes grow in
power they seem to take on this orange
glow which is a similar glow to this cut
effect so if I had to guess I think this
special effect might have once been used
to represent a great Rune at one point
perhaps great runes were something that
you picked up in the Overworld but maybe
from software pivoted away from that
eventually and made these physical
representations of them instead because
that would explain why this effect isn't
in the game but what do you guys think I
can't think of many other items worthy
of such an aura especially since that
aura seems linked to the Elden ring and
its shattering but maybe I'm wrong and
this represents something else important
a legendary arterial Leaf perhaps one
could only dream
for number four many of Elden Ring's
weapons are of course inspired by
equivalents out in the real world but
one you might not have expected to be
real is this the urumi a weapon that
traces its Origins back to the Indian
Iron Age while Elden Rings arumi is a
Whip made out of the liquid metal of a
silver tear the Indian arumi is made out
of flexible edged steel measuring three
quarters to one inch in width a Sri
Lankan variation has even been
discovered with up to 32 blades attached
allegedly this weapon was supposed to be
handled like a flail and while the light
blades made it much lighter than a flail
the arumi required the wielder to be
extremely dexterous and control momentum
with each swing with techniques
including many spins and agile Maneuvers
records show that these long-reaching
spins made the weapon particularly well
suited to fighting against multiple
opponents though I'd wager that the
wielder was a danger to themselves as
well with this weapon it's quite an
invention nonetheless
speaking of inventions did you know that
Elden ring supposedly has its own genius
inventor and while their identity is
supposed to be a bit of a mystery I
think we can safely guess who it is
so the pulley bow and pulley crossbow
read as follows this weapon utilizes a
series of pulleys and strings the
complex mechanism which required
Advanced mathematical and mechanical
understanding to craft was likely made
by a certain genius who learned golden
order fundamentalism so that narrows it
down as few characters we know could be
classified as genius practitioners of
golden order fundamentalism
Radigan would probably qualify and gold
mask would too especially considering
his mathematical genius in Golden order
fundamentalism but there's another
candidate mikola and I personally
believe mikla is the genius in question
who crafted the pulley weapons because
mikola wasn't just proficient in Golden
order fundamentalism he was also noted
in other areas of the law as an expert
Craftsman Gary calls him a true Artisan
for his creation of the gold needle the
valkyrie's prosthesis mikola created for
his sister is also regarded as a
Masterwork of craftsmanship and now we
have the pulley weapons which themselves
have a golden hue that is found in all
of mikola's crafted items carrying this
logic further and realizing that it's
also now possible that Torrance spectral
Steed finger Whistle Too might have been
created by mikola it's described as a
delicate goldwork ring it's visually
striking and it doubles as a finger
whistle which is pretty genius
we also recently speculated that mikola
might be the owner of torrent in my
video on Eldon Ring's upcoming expansion
and I reckon the fine craftsmanship of
this ring might validate that theory a
little bit further looking back it's
amazing how present mikola has been in
the story all along without him
physically appearing yet at all
Michael's character is far more
fulfilled in the cut content of the game
where he has dialogue items weapons and
more I'll personally be looking out for
a lot of this cut content to return in
Shadow of the earth tree and he's not
the only cut character I'll be looking
out for because a lot of minor
characters fascinate me as well one cut
minor character is called Estelle and
she was apparently once an alchemist
devoted to study of the ERD tree as The
Story Goes she witnessed the discovery
of the cracked Crystal tear which is
that tear you can put into your flask of
wondrous physic with explosive results
while she did note that this was a
failed experiment I still believed that
this Crystal tier had spawned a new
dangerous school of thought and the cut
item description states that she was
utterly Enchanted by it this is a cool
description and I'm sad that it was lost
props to Sakura odubi who translated and
restored this description from the
Brazilian Portuguese closed Network test
files
so Estelle is a French name derived from
the Latin Stella meaning star and when
it comes to from software's games it's
always a good idea to look at the
etymology of names too see if there
isn't a little more information we can
glean for example when it comes to
mikola Michael is an Old English
adjective embodying an abundance or
great magnitude of something which ties
in nicely to cut content regarding
mikola's relation to an age of abundance
to contrast his sister's Affliction of
rot and Decay the name mikola also
appears to be a version of the name
Mikhail which in turn is borrowed from
Hebrew Mikhail meaning who is like God
perhaps alluding to mikola's
relationship to America and Radigan or
his status as an Imperium a candidate
for godhood while it's important to
treat these discoveries with a healthy
degree of skepticism if you look at from
software's long history of creating
characters it's clear that they do take
etymology into account sometimes for
more examples go and check out luwajuk's
Twitter threat on the etymology of other
names and characters Linked In the
description because there's a lot more
that I haven't yet mentioned another
interesting etymological twist that I
recently discovered is the Cathedral of
Manus zealous perched atop the plateau
of the Moonlight altar in Leonia
longtime fans might recognize the name
Manus associating it with the monster
whose gigantic hand pulls you into the
past in the DLC of the first Dark Souls
and it's that hand that both the monster
and the cathedral inherit their name
from Manus is the Latin term for hand
and zealous is a word meaning something
related to the heavens thus the
Cathedral of manicellus could conceive
may also be known as the Cathedral of
the Heavenly hand alluding to the
position of the two fingers that lurk
below it
while Randy's two fingers end up forever
entombed in their cave below the
cathedral there exists another burial
site of Interest a stone's throw away in
Leonia recently Twitter user Ashen
highlighted to me that an illusory wall
passed the entrance of the Royal lucaria
Academy reveals a set of seven
sarcophagi sarkov guy that looks
suspiciously similar to the ones
contained within the wandering
mausoleums scattered throughout the
lands between perhaps the seven tombs
represent the founders of the seven
conspectus that formed teachings in the
academy as there are seven crowns that
represent each branch so it's not
unreasonable to assume that these tombs
would be prepared in the academy though
it's worth noting that the witch Selen
still seems to be alive and well though
she certainly jumped out of her past
body at least once in the past while the
conspectives founders may have been
glorified and memorialized close to
their home there's another character who
may not have received such a ceremonious
burial close to the base of the odd Tree
in Lane Dell is this a single grave with
some rather curious loot in front of it
three smoldering butterflies
it's odd that they've been deposited
here as an item instead of as a swarm of
butterflies as they usually are right
well this line of thought LED Reddit
user this name taken deposit that this
grave may be dedicated to Melania given
the smoldering butterflies and its out
of the way position this Theory builds
off my own Theory regarding the Children
of America and radican a while back I
suggested that each butterfly item in
the game was linked to each child of
America and Radigan the eternally young
nascent butterfly for mikola the rotten
aeonian butterfly for Melania and
smoldering butterfly for melaner who is
known as the kindling Maiden so of
course I personally love the idea that
this could be malena's grave set near to
the base of the earth tree where she was
born to commemorate her loss of body
perhaps but at the same time it's still
just that a theory nowhere near being
facts no matter how much I'd like it to
be number 11. so when you explore an
instance of Elden Ring's World there is
about a 0.5 chance that any lesser enemy
will spawn with the golden eye effect
and a one percent chance for more
imposing enemies but did you know that
this effect can also appear on enemies
that don't have eyes at any rate it can
appear on enemies that don't have
conventionally placed eyes take the
jellyfish for example despite not having
any obvious eyes the Golden Glow can
still appear on four spots around their
body I wonder are there any other
eyeless enemies that this effect appears
on number 12. so when you usually use a
weapon skill without the required Stat
or FP the skill will often still perform
just without as much damage or special
effects so in the case of the envoy
horns from software couldn't still have
them shoot bubbles that would make sense
with no FP or the faith for the weapon
so what's funny is that their solution
is this a pathetic Hollow air sound
instead
number 13. so it's been long known that
Miyazaki is a big fan of tabletop games
and the worlds therein for example an
old Rolling Stone interview conducted
near the release of Dark Souls 3 notes
that Miyazaki has a copy of sorcery in
his personal Library this game book
published in 1983 takes the reader on an
adventure through its world as either a
warrior or a wizard and it's clear that
Miyazaki or at least the design team on
Elden ring was inspired by this book on
some level when designing their most
recent title The Smoking Gun is this a
character called the site Master
Sergeant who Bears an uncanny
resemblance to girian off near the
all-knowing not only is the I symbolism
shared by the two extremely relevant but
he's actually standing in the exact same
very unique pose that Gideon of near is
in when he confronts you towards the end
of the game I always thought Gideon's
arrogant pose here was pretty ridiculous
to the point where I was wondering what
the team was trying to convey when they
designed him in this pose so it's
actually pretty satisfying to realize
that it was a reference to Gideon's
Origins all along
since Gideon was clearly inspired by
sorcery I believe that the flame of
frenzy was likely inspired by the book
as well in a previous version of Elden
ring kalei was known as the red eyes
Merchant and the flame of frenzy was
known instead as the curse of red eyes
well in sorcery there are those known as
the red eyes of karei who when they open
their eyelids are able to burn
everything they see The Story Goes On to
explain that these eyes of these
creatures continually emit beams of
searing heat burning anything they look
upon it probably goes without saying
that yeah the red eyes of sorcery and
the red eyes of Elden ring sound
extremely similar this next secret comes
to us from Loki the author of Abyssal
archive which I showed off earlier again
please check out that book after this
video is done if you're interested in
this book Loki has a section where he
talks about how thief the scaleless
dragon was embraced by royalty that's
how dark souls puts it but the phrase
embraced by royalty doesn't actually
give us the full picture to understand
properly we need to understand what the
original Japanese version of Dark Souls
says about safe and the cultural context
of the words they used here the Japanese
text forsith uses the term gaiseki which
refers specifically to family of the
King's mother consort or princess in
other words the Japanese text makes it
clear that Seth married into an Orlando
royalty through a woman of gwyn's kin
for political benefit something that
would have been more obvious to a
Japanese Dark Souls player but not to
its English-speaking audience gaiseki
actually shows up again in Elden ring as
well when used to describe Rani Reichard
and Rodan becoming demigods when their
father Radigan married into America's
Family interestingly while the word
gaiseki has historically been used to
refer to marrying into a male king or
emperor's family the kanji isn't
inherently gendered so Elden ring is
able to genderflip this term to apply to
the relatives of Queen America instead
and that's it thank you for watching and
again please check out Abyssal archive
in the links below if you want to hear
me go on about Dark Souls Lore for hours
on end or check out the physical book if
you want to enshrine Dark Souls as lore
for yourself but other than that thanks
again and I'll see you again very soon
[Music]